me piden convertir irradian es y menos
peters irradian es a grados como le voy
a hacer bueno pues con la misma idea que
he usado en los vídeos anteriores
voy a tener aquí circunferencia y
recuerden que dar una vuelta completa
son dos piedras yanes si lo queremos ver
en radiales déjenme escribirlo aquí dos
pi radiales y por otra parte yo tengo
que dar una vuelta completa en grados lo
que siempre he utilizado desde hace
mucho tiempo es que son 360 grados
entonces
recuerden que dos radiales es lo mismo
que 360 grados que es lo mismo que dar
una vuelta entera y por lo tanto si yo
divido estas dos partes de la igualdad
entre dos me va a quedar que pi radiales
es igual a 180 grados aquí está mi
simbolito de grados pero recuerden que
también lo puedo escribir como grados
no quiero confundirlos con esto entonces
en esta ocasión si voy a dejar mi
circulito abel a 2 y radiantes desigual
a 360 grados voy a dividir entre 2
entonces esto entre 2
y la otra parte pues también hay que
dividirlo entre dos dividido ambas
partes de mi igualdad entre 2 2 entre 2
se van y me queda que pierda de danés es
igual a 360 entre 2 grados 360 entre 2
es lo mismo que 180 entonces 180 grados
que por cierto esta era la otra igualdad
famosa que les contaba yo a la vez
pasada y que creen además es la solución
de mi primer medida angular que yo
quería convertir de mi primer inciso
como lo quieran ver de este problema
convierte piedras yanesha grados ya lo
tengo son 180 grados y ya tengo la
primera parte de este problema la
primera solución ahora te pregunta
cuánto valen menos peters radiales a
grados recuerden que cuando tenemos un
ángulo negativo estamos girando al a
favor de las manecillas del reloj
estamos creando al revés
este de verde que tengo aquí es irradian
es y menos peters irradian es tendríamos
que girar al revés ahora como lo pasamos
de radiantes a grados y para esto no es
muy difícil lo único que tenemos que
acordarnos es que los radiales
y quedar dividiendo y los grados nos
tienen que quedar arriba para que un
resultado me dé en grados es decir a
menos pi tercios radiales lo voy a
multiplicar por uno pero porque uno por
un uno especial el uno que me queda va a
tener 180 grados entre mi radiales
recuerden que estas dos cosas son lo
mismo y por lo tanto estoy multiplicando
por uno pero bueno recuerdan que lo
importante es que los radiales les
queden dividiendo para que los radiales
se puedan cancelar 180 grados es lo
mismo que irradian es y entonces
radiales con radiales se van a cancelar
porque están dividiendo justo lo que
querían y también creo que se va a pique
con pi por lo tanto vamos a hacerlo
tenemos los radiales se van y tachamos
los radiales tachamos a pin vamos a
cancelar también a pippi que multiplica
a pique divide se van y me queda simple
y sencillamente menos 180 entre 3 que
por cierto menos 180 entre 3 ya lo
sabemos resolver 180 entre 13 es lo
mismo que 60 y el signo menos lo pongo
también y este resultado va a estar dado
en grados menos 60 grados
y ya con esto he terminado la solución
de este problema que tenía en un
principio